if you've ever wanted to unleash your
inner DJ and you have an iPad then you
might want to check out the idj live
from New mark which also comes with the
DJ for iPad app now what it does is it
goes into your ipod music library and it
easily pulls music to different sources
and it helps you scratch them together
now if you want to do this manually
there are two little scratch turntables
on here that you could use to fine-tune
your craft if you are like myself and
not very musically inclined it has an
auto mixed mode where it will go into
your playlists and will analyze your
music and will mix appropriate songs
together in such a way that maybe you
might want to start a second career as a
DJ there is no retail price that has
been set but you can look for the idj
live later this year